we don't know where things are going it
makes it very difficult for people to
put their money in growth stocks like
tech stocks because of the zero interest
because of the rate raise issue that
you've outlined it makes it very
difficult for people to buy Cloud
software because how are you going to
decide how to expand your business if
you don't know when this where this
economy is going to settle out so it's
possible now that the failure of Silicon
Valley Bank right the failure of
Signature Bank
tells the FED tells dronepal maybe
enough is enough and they stop and that
you know kind of counterintuitively ends
up bolstering Tech like some people have
joked that Silicon Valley bank took one
for the team to help their friends out
in the tech industry and you're starting
to see right now I mean what's going on
in the stock market today is a rotation
out of financial services companies and
into technology which is just this
galaxy brain situation but that's where
we are
[Music]
thank you
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast the author of always day one and
the big Tech substack newsletter as well
as CNBC contributor Alex canterowitz
welcome Alex thank you Andrew great to
see you
great to see you too so Alex this was
the craziest week ever for just about
anyone that's touching Tech you are
deeply embedded in the technology
Universe you and I were both at South by
Southwest uh how was this past number of
days for you and the folks around you
definitely one of the weirdest stretches
of days I've ever had reporting on Tech
and I've been doing this for a while I
mean I've never had a stretch of days
where you go into a meeting with a
founder and they want to show you the
product they're working on but they're
also wondering how they're going to pay
their employees I was with Kevin Systrom
the founder of Instagram a couple days
ago recording for my big technology
podcast and before we sat down he's like
yeah I've got all my money in Silicon
Valley Bank and I know that money is
going to be there eventually but the
timeline is the question and he
basically said he was ready to pay out
of his own pocket if he wasn't going to
get those funds now luckily he's gotten
the funds so that's not a scenario that
he's had to endure but this has been a
real issue for every founder uh in
Silicon Valley who's either been touched
directly or indirectly by Silicon Valley
Banks Silicon Valley Banks failure dude
he sounds like he was calmer and the 98
of the people I know but he's also
richer than you know yeah exactly
it helps when you sell your company for
a billion dollars to Facebook so I'm
going to give you a more normal
experience I knew a Founder who had half
a million in Silicon Valley Bank and it
was meant to cover payroll for his
little company and then he he was so
stressed out he was uh near tears
um where he thought to himself oh my
gosh like what am I going to do there
was a children's book publisher that
sent out an email saying hey we had our
money with Silicon Valley Bank there's a
retailer near me called a camp store
like that they they had an emergency
sale so like it like that there was this
terrible misconception I saw that it was
all just Mega Ballers and mega rich
people I mean like my thought was like
the employees at the camp store are not
like what anyone thinks of as Silicon
Valley employees but they would have
been out of a job potentially if uh the
feds hadn't stepped up which is a
fascinating secondary storyline here
that I've been watching very closely is
yes of course the people that are
actually impacted by and large are
regular folks or you know people working
in business who might be doing pretty
well but aren't
by any by any stretch of the imagination
billionaires and yet right so many
people in society reacted as if it was
fine to let this Bank fail and stick it
to Silicon Valley and it just reminds me
of thinking back to the early days of as
the tech industry grew in San Francisco
and in New York and how excited people
were about tech and how Tech was
supposed to challenge the incumbents and
this was all about product and then
eventually this financialization of the
industry took over and for whatever
reason now Tech is known not for its
products but for the money side of it
and for the loud VCS who are clamoring
you know for this policy or that or
um you know obnoxiously advocating some
position and I think this is a real
liability for Silicon Valley that you
know even though we all have Tech in our
lives and appreciate it we're able to
record this podcast because of recent
Tech Innovation right sitting across
from each other in a browser even still
so many people felt so little empathy
for Silicon Valley I think that's a
major liability and we're just starting
to sort through the implications on that
front yeah I
you either have to be four against
someone uh uh and I put out something
where it's like look it's not a
political argument it's the financial
system you know what I mean like like
that that random children's book
publisher is not a political football
and like rooting for them to fail struck
me as Madness uh and but this is someone
who has been an entrepreneur knew dozens
of people that that were personally
impacted I guess if it's an abstraction
uh it's a little different uh but I was
very pained by some of the folks that I
here to for kind of thought were
rational who were taking the side of
like oh let this bang fail
yeah look
I understand the impulse of saying these
companies that you see as extracting the
wealth from society and being this uh
layer on top of things like labor for
instance that you know is promised to
make life better but ends up taking all
the product of that labor and converting
it into profits like I understand the
impulse and that's again something that
Silicon Valley is going to have to
reckon with and I'm not saying this as
like a detractor I'm you know rooting
for Tech right but
um you know the fact that so is that the
fact that people Channel this anger and
weren't even able to see the folks on
the other side of this the front line
workers that were going to make payroll
or the small companies that bank with
Silicon Valley Bank are the people who
had their retirement you know for that
matter in the bank I mean I'm curious
Andrew what you think about that right
not to turn the tables on you but what
do you think about the fact that Silicon
Valley has been perceived this way yeah
you know so there's been this real shift
where I started a non-profit Venture for
America in 2011 and back then
entrepreneurship was seen as more or
less
uh positive pro-social Endeavor uh you
know if you start a business and create
jobs like that's a good thing and then
Somewhere over the last
12 years
entrepreneurship now is a mixed
opportunity and a lot of the folks who
are the most prominent Builders are now
villainized uh you know and and
sometimes it's because it's to me it's a
product of the polarization our society
is now suffering with and I will say
like our economy has gotten more and
more extreme and winner take all and so
if you're a rational person like it's
getting harder and harder to be like oh
yeah everything's going right
um in large part because of the
financialization of everything which you
described and I do want to take a minute
to try and set the stage for what the
heck goes next because at this point
Silicon Valley Banks and bailed out yay
uh and uh by the way bailout's not even
the right term I mean like you know like
bailout means the people still have
their jobs they don't means the
shareholders got money they didn't
like really all this means that
depositors can get their money which is
uh to me categorically the right place
to land but they're going to be other
shoes dropping in the days ahead and
you've had this fascinating Advantage
because you've been reporting on big
Tech big Tech has already experienced
this Mega correction uh over the last
eight nine months in large part because
of rising interest rates there's like an
interest rate theory of everything going
on right now yes where what I I and the
way I explain it to folks is that look
if you have zero percent interest rates
and I have money then I can't get any
risk-free Returns on it and then if you
tell me look here's this tech company
it's going to be big in 10 years it'll
be like okay I guess I'll just bid up
the stock I'll bid the stock up to the
moon but now if you tell me I can get
five percent risk free on Treasury bonds
compounded over 10 years that's like 62
percent that's not terrible and then if
you show me some company that's going to
be huge in 10 years you're like does it
make money like is it going to be a lot
bigger than 62 percent bigger in 10
years like why do I want to take this
risk so you had companies like meta that
you report on very heavily how much has
metal lost in terms of its value I mean
depends on which point you want to pick
like
they were I'm gonna just go back in the
envelope they were in the trillion
dollar range you know they were like all
they were about to join the likes of
apple and Amazon and Google in that
range and they dropped all the way down
to 250 billion in in thereabouts I mean
your listeners will fact check me on
this but it was something like a 70
decline in stock value which is yeah
unbelievable for a company that was that
big and that powerful
yeah you lose two-thirds of your value I
mean that's
we're starting to see the byproduct now
which the just this week Mark Zuckerberg
announced the second round of 10 000
headcount layoffs after the first one
that happened about a month ago so this
company is responding and and you know
it does unfortunately come at a cost of
jobs for people
um the other side of it is that they've
been hiring so much right so they're
still above their pre-pandemic head
count numbers but to when you take a job
you put all your eggs in one basket
right by definition so think about the
20 000 people who
left their current jobs or finally got a
job after seeking one
put their lot in with meta and now are
going to be looking again in a much more
difficult economy and this has happened
in meta inside meta inside alphabet
inside Amazon inside Microsoft it's
happening everywhere and up until this
point this has largely been concentrated
in the big tech companies now the one
interesting thing about the Silicon
Valley Bank breakdown is the Fed has
seen that its campaign of rising
interest rates can actually break things
this is a direct impact of the FED
Rising raising the interest rate now of
course it was a problem from risk
management for Silicon Valley Bank but
it also the risk that they didn't manage
for was a sort of unprecedented rate
raise and that's what we're they
freaking bought tea bills exactly
exactly I mean conceptually the safest
thing you could do you're right and so
maybe the FED will now see this is sort
of the weird take that I'm hearing a lot
but maybe the FED will now see that its
rate raises but break things in the
underlying problems with inflation are
starting to get better and it stops
those rate raises and one of the big
problems we've had is uncertainty in the
economy we don't know where things are
going it makes it very difficult for
people to put their money in growth
stocks like tech stocks because of the
zero interest because of the rate raise
issue that you've outlined it makes it
very difficult for people to buy Cloud
software because how are you going to
decide how to expand your business if
you don't know when this where this
economy is going to settle out so it's
possible now that the failure of Silicon
Valley Bank right the failure of
Signature Bank
tells the FED tells drone Powell maybe
enough is enough and they stop and that
you know kind of counter-intuitively
ends up bolstering Tech like some people
have joked that Silicon Valley bank took
one for the team to help their friends
out in the tech industry and you're
starting to see right now I mean what's
going on in the stock market today is a
rotation out of financial services
companies and into technology which is
just this galaxy brain situation but
that's where we are
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
having a good mattress has always struck
me as one of the best investments you
can make because you spend a lot of time
on that mattress and having a healthy
night's sleep gives you energy for the
day keeps you healthy makes you capable
of doing all the things you want to do
why would you sleep on a mattress that's
made for someone other than you
especially in 2023 with Helix sleep you
can take a personalized quiz get one of
their 14 unique mattresses sent right to
your door have a hundred night trial and
a 10 plus year warranty yeah they have
that much confidence in their products
in part because they're manufactured
right here in the USA and it's the
number one mattress picked by GQ and
Wired Magazine Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
[Music]
well well the banks are going to be in a
tough spot for the foreseeable and
you're going to see more Banks capsize
uh moving forward so here's the interest
rate Theory of Everything so we went
through Tech uh meta loses 70 of its
stock value Netflix maybe 60 like you
can look at it and it's not always
Extreme as uh as meta but a lot of them
have gotten shaved in half I mean we're
really really very significant
devaluations uh and then now you're
seeing the financial sector coming under
massive pressure
um in part because they feasted on an
era of free money
um you figure there are going to be some
other banks that made some version of
the same error that Silicon Valley Bank
made there's a potential run on credit
Swiss in Europe and you don't know what
the Regulators are going to do there's a
potential run on First Republic which is
a small Regional Bank here in New York
uh where you are you based in the Bay
Area or here in New York Alex yeah I
actually moved back to New York I'm a
New York native moved back to New York
from San Francisco about a year ago okay
so if you're back in New York then you
know this about 50 of uh Midtown
Manhattan offices are unoccupied uh that
that's verified by people I know in that
industry and they're having a real
problem trying to get tenants uh they
had some tenants that obviously like had
multi-year leases and then those leases
are are coming up some of them aren't
renewing they're having a hard time uh
getting tenants in and so the cash flows
associated with these Office Buildings
are dropping uh and the debt loads are
still the same the so they're getting
loan payments and refinancings and so
they're having a hard time figuring out
what is this office building worth now
it's like well if you based it on how
much rent you're getting it's a lot
lower than it was but no one wants to
acknowledge that and so you're going to
have this massive revaluation of various
office space uh and that's going to
largely fall on the banks because a lot
of these even these management companies
are going to say look now like you know
I owe more money on this building than
the building's even worth take the
building they'll go to the back and be
like here are the keys it's like if you
had a mortgage on your house and the
mortgage started being more than the
house was worth you'd be like take my
house so they're going to be a lot of
revaluations in that sector and that's
like you know like tens and tens of
billions of dollars of value
yeah it's scary when you think about I
mean it's the same thing with the banks
right they they had these assets on
their balance sheets that looked good
when they bought them but the interest
rate Rises right it's a similar
environmental change like covid
sending people to hybrid workplaces
instead of working at working in the
office and these bets I think the bet
you talk about real estate you know the
BET and the bank they're long-term bets
that need somewhat stable conditions to
pay off over there to be over time
because you build in some risk maybe a
little bit here maybe a little bit there
and you're going to be okay you don't
build on Earth shaking things uh like
for instance covid or maybe less
earth-shaking but still as startling if
you're a banker right going from
basically zero to five percent interest
rates and although all the models that
you build and then how are you going to
take them to go from zero to five
percent it was faster than most people
thought extremely fast I mean I feel
like we were like what in 21 the the top
of the market was January 21. so we're
here in or yeah or even later we're here
in March 2023 and all of a sudden we're
living in an entirely different Market
development and Andrew yeah the single
biggest thing that humans uh can see is
the difference is that you'll actually
get paid interest in your savings
account
because we've been in a zero interest
rate environment for so long that that
was like you know like totally brand
brand new feeling but now all the people
who took their money and put it in you
know in stocks because they couldn't
make any money on their savings now
they're seeing a sea of red in their
trading accounts and they can't you know
unless you want you're willing to take a
loss they can't easily move it to these
rates so I mean I guess like now you
have to operate with a totally new uh
but new new mentality but even for
individual investors right who are
thinking how am I going to plan for
retirement you know you're almost caught
in the same place as someone like a
Silicon Valley Bank was because you're
making these long-term rate long-term
bets you're not getting anything short
term now all of a sudden you can get
short term in your account that you're
betting on the long term looks you know
pretty uh depressing by the way Andrew
I'm curious what you think about the
fact that this was developed uh that
this developed so quickly from from like
a mobile perspective right like the VCS
texting like this Bank Run was extremely
fast do we need that yeah it was just
them them on uh you know uh channels and
yeah exactly what's that probably and be
like hey guys you might want to pull
your money from this thing and then but
the fact that money can fly away so
quickly you know because you're you're
well versed in the policy standpoint do
we need new laws to like ensure that
banks have more liquidity for instance
on hand
to account for the risk that people on
their cell phones or on their laptops
can coordinate at this speed and sync a
bank you know overnight because every
bank is sort of liable in that in that
way yeah one of the big problems that
they have with the regulations is that
they have these periodic stress tests
and things can change so quickly that
like what would be an appropriate period
you know what I mean uh you know like uh
once a year is I think what they're
doing with the large Banks now
um and uh a lot can change in 10 months
you know so in a way what you need is
some kind of dashboard that's plugged
into uh what the bank's reserves are and
what kind of risk they're taking and
what their portfolios are being valued
at and not just show up and be like hey
guys like what's going on now because
circumstances can change to your point
um I mean
a lot of these services are getting
commoditized you know and people are
ruthless maybe a while ago it might have
been like oh I like this guy you know I
have a relationship now it's like no
it's like I mean even now though the
deposits have been guaranteed there are
so many people right now I wish we could
find a number but there's so many people
that are pulling their money out of
financial institutions and plugging them
in to JPMorgan Chase Bank of America
Citigroup because they're like okay
these banks are too big to fail
um I had a friend ask me like what's the
point of regional Banks and you know
that was painful because I know the
point of regional Banks is actually to
do things like Finance small businesses
and like like do things in the community
and Community like these Regional Banks
and Community Banks used to be uh a huge
partner in in these businesses around
the country like it developed but now
you've seen this Mega consolidation of
Finance by the way very much parallel to
the mega consolidation and Tech that you
do Chronicle in big Tech
um that there's like this myth of
competition in American life but then
like it's becoming increasingly winner
take all exactly so another two
Executives I was speaking with on big
technology podcast are folks that had
spanked with Silicon Valley Bank or
other Regional Banks over time and had
actually tried one of them had tried to
bank with a bigger Bank in the middle of
another
problematic moment for a bank that he
was working with and about 10 10 15
years ago the problem for these folks
and this is again you know talk about
why we need Regional Banks is you try if
you're a small business person and you
try to go to one of these big Banks and
get the customer service that you need
to allow yourself to operate they don't
care about you
I mean they're so big that you mean
nothing to them
and then you go to a Regional Bank all
of a sudden you do have somebody on the
phone you do have them working on
products that are going to make sense
for you and if that goes away
then you know your your business this is
a real business issue your business is
going to be hamstrung and unable to do
business the way that you need to be and
then what happens right because again we
talked about all these Downstream
effects the people that work for these
companies the company's ability to grow
they power Innovation and if that dries
up it's a really bad sign for the
American economy
thank you
hey YouTube hope you're enjoying
thoughtful interviews with non-jerks if
you want more hit like And subscribe
appreciate it so much
I think if you look at the Savings and
Loan crisis that happened in the wake of
the 70s so the the biggest analog we
have how old are you now Alex I'm 35.
all right man I've got a few years on
you I've got you know
um like a decade Plus on you so the if
you want to figure out what the heck
we're going through now
um you really do look at the 70s because
the 70s you had high inflation so what
do they do they jacked up interest rates
uh and then uh you wound up with a
banking crisis I don't know if that
sounds familiar to anyone I wonder
you had the the Savings and Loan crisis
and back then
um there were many many more Banks and
so they had uh literally something like
20 plus of the banks failed
um because they jacked up interest rates
um and so now we're in 2023 they've
jacked up interest rates much faster
than most anyone expected apparently and
you had essentially zero percent
interest rates for you know 14 years so
you had probably a whole generation of
work workers they were like yeah it's
like this all the time
and CEOs and bankers
yeah everyone loses track really of what
could happen once you've let their
behavior continue for a while yeah I
mean 14 years is a while you know so in
a way you can't blame them um then you
jack up interest rates now it's going to
break a lot of banks I mean Silicon
Valley Bank uh signature just the
beginning like if they had not come in
and backstopped these Banks you would
have seen in my opinion you know like
the whole thing would have gone down
yeah yeah you you would have seen a
whole conflagration
um of much of the financial system
really really quick which is one reason
why I thought it was crazy that anyone
was was
um you know waffling
honestly like even with this backstop
you're going to see tens of billions of
deposits flow towards the top three
Banks okay so first of all I just need
to clarify something when I say I'm
rooting for Tech it's not rooting for
big Tech I'm rooting for a healthy
technology industry that not only
delivers rewards for shareholders but
makes our society better and that's sort
of the work that I do at Big technology
is just try to figure out how that works
and speaking with people and writing
stories that sort of look at the
competitive and the growth angle you
know from that point so I'm right there
with you Alec that being said that being
said you know I you bring up a really
interesting point Andrew because one of
the interesting things that isn't being
talked about enough here is that Banks
like Silicon Valley Bank lobbied for a
loosening of regulations saying that
they are not like the societal critical
Banks like a JP Morgan is therefore they
should be allowed to operate with a
little bit more leverage which in
retrospect
is astonishing because we now see what
happened right where they did fail and
not only did they fail they failed and
their failure risked causing harm to the
rest of the banking industry so I'm kind
of curious what you think again from a
policy standpoint
do we now still want to draw a
distinction between these you know sort
of I guess we look at them as these two
big to fail Banks and Regional Banks
because once one Regional bit goes down
there's a serious contagion effect I
mean we saw that right that contagion
effect is real it's no longer
hypothetical yeah so the threshold to be
a non-systemic bank was 250 billion in
assets I think Silicon Valley was at 212
or something like that right yeah so
Silicon Valley bag was like the biggest
thanks underneath this exclusion uh on
the face of it you do have to say that
um that
deregulation uh was not very smart I
mean you'd have to look at the face of
it yeah two bags blow up you know you
just deregulated them now the fact that
Barney Frank was on the board of one of
them I mean the author of The you know
co-author of Dodd-Frank I well what that
is is just a symptom of the fact that
after you're in office there's a
straight line to becoming a lobbyist and
uh you know you look at it I think
something like two-thirds of former
members of Congress head to Industry and
then they get paid a lot of money to
Lobby uh yeah and undo the common sense
regulation they they brought to the fore
while in office the system and this is
my day job by the way is like I'm trying
to cure the political system of its
perverse incentives
which is a fun task a fun challenge
um but that like that that's an emblem
to it and like people you know like the
Dems are blaming the Republicans and
deregulation Republicans are blaming
democrats for either being asleep at the
switch or uh you know being ideological
in their approach or for bailing of the
banks which again like this is not a
bailout and like I thought the backstop
was totally correct and and you know
we're in danger of it slipping into this
uh everything's in ideological argument
Zone uh and then realize become
secondary like we're entering this
strange looking glass period where to
your point it's like well you know I
don't care about what happens to real
people if they're not my people however
you define my people you know it's it's
exactly it's super dangerous but I want
to return to what what we were just
saying about how so interest rates have
essentially gone from zero to five
percent in a matter of months
um it's uh it's devalued tech companies
in some cases very very dramatically
it's now causing this seizure in uh the
banking industry that is going to
continue in my opinion for quite some
time
um and you're going to have more failing
institutions uh and then the government
is going to have to think like ah we we
backstabbing this one too what are we
doing here
commercial real estate is another shoe
to drop that those buildings are going
to have to be revalued like people are
still just crossing their fingers and be
like maybe it'll all just return to
normal and and then they're gonna have
to bite the bullet at some point the
other major component of this that's
been uh very very dramatically hit by
Rising interest rates is residential
home sales
um because I just saw that last month
was like the lowest level of home sales
in over a decade it's just people are
not
uh selling or buying homes and there are
a bunch of reasons for that but a huge
reason for that is that mortgage rates
are now so much higher than they were
that your freaking monthly mortgage
payment is giving folks sticker shock
and they're like wait a minute I can't
pay I can't pay that every month
um but then if you're a homeowner you
you want what your home is quote unquote
worth
and so like there's a disconnect uh and
uh homes aren't being sold
yeah and if you're a homeowner you're
going to buy another home probably
so then you're saying I'm going to sell
now in a moment where people probably
want to pay less for my house I'm about
to live somewhere else and now I'm gonna
have to deal with this rate so yeah it
is it is an absolute freezing of the
typical
yeah the typical home buying process I
mean you know someone's smacking the
middle of the millennial generation you
know a lot of us have sort of given up
on the dream of of home ownership as it
was right because we're sort of we've
sort of been Iced Out of and I mean gen
Z you know God bless them like we'll see
if it gets any better but it doesn't
look like I feel so bad for how much
young people have been shafted in this
country uh in so many ways uh you know
Millennials gen z uh the generation
after gen Z like we have just screwed
young people so royally
um and it pains me but uh if you're a
first time home buyer I have no idea
what you're going to do it's like low
inventory High mortgage rates prices
that will improve yeah you're probably
going to rent for a little longer
yeah
so but at the same time like you know
you don't want that to be forced on
everyone
it's a terrible situation you don't want
that to be this you want people to be
able to buy homes and build wealth in
that way and not end up you know having
their paycheck go to someone else's
pocket all the time did you see there's
a city council by the way the rental
market is not great either did you see
there's a there's a story in the times
about this city council member of New
York who won as a young person and is
moving out of his parents home and is
trying to find an apartment somewhere in
New York City and struggling to do it I
mean of course I guess there's like a
little bit of uh you know you should be
able to find somewhere to live on a city
council salary but I mean it does like
it should never end up to the get to the
point that is a story you know and the
city council men in uh and women in New
York City get paid a lot like what's
like a hundred and something thousand
dollars a year yeah it's six figures for
sure
foreign
if you know me you know that I think
that our data should be ours and that
big Tech right now is running roughshod
on our autonomy our agency our privacy
for sure one way to help turn the tables
on big Tech is to use expressvpn like I
do when I surf the web it keeps you
private by piping you in to another IP
address it's what big companies use it
was rated the number one VPN that's
virtual private Network by CNET wired
and more let's take it back from Big
Tech Stop handing over your personal
data to the quasi-monopolies that mine
our activity and sell our info for their
profit not ours protect yourself with a
VPN I trust to keep me and mine safe
online visit expressvpn.com Yang that's
expresvpn.com to get three extra months
free
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
so to your argument about what the heck
the fed's going to do interest rates at
this level are breaking things they're
going to break a lot of things there's
still been a lot of deferred pain a lot
of
devaluations and revaluations that
people are just punting on and being
like maybe if I hang on that this will
work itself out the markets are now
acting like maybe Jerome Powell is going
to stop jacking up rates in my opinion
even if rates stay at this level we're
going to see things break right in the
left uh and uh you know I I've been
fairly gloomy on this stuff so to rewind
again to the 70s example you had high
inflation you had uh volcker was the FED
chairman of that time raise interest
rates uh and they went very very high I
think you talked about like double
digits at that point you then had
stagflation
malaise uh Jimmy Carter loses uh his
re-election campaign
and back then in a major banking crisis
and back then
Finance was a much smaller part of the
economy than it is now today
financialization has washed over Tech a
lot of business certainly real estate
and so when people are looking around
saying like uh who's to blame who's to
blame I try and tell them it's like look
we are in Uncharted territory
now like the closest analog was 50 years
ago and it got really really rough like
historically bad rough and there's every
reason to expect that this time is going
to follow a similar pattern
um because you've had
essentially zero interest rates for
longer than you'd ever had in in history
and then you raise them
at historically fast rates uh like that
there's going to be a lot of pain to go
around
yeah and by the way so now we've like
there's one thing we haven't really
talked about that might be worth
bringing up so you think about okay so
what happens obviously raising the rates
this fast has broken some things and put
us in a situation where you know our
stock market has uh contracted in some
ways and we might see more economic pain
so okay what happens if those interest
rates come down so you'll probably start
to see some of the zero interest rate
phenomena's that you saw previously
right which is that people are looking
for more risky places to find their
money like so they'll go crypto or
they'll go into places like the meme
stocks like the game stock and GameStop
and the AMC and you know whatever
whatever Reddit decides that they like
that day so okay you say well why isn't
that so bad he gets more money to
startups well here's the wild card right
is that inflation then might start to
rise now inflation has been persistent
in a way that has been hotter than the
FED anticipated after making these rate
raises and many Market Watchers did and
there's a lot of students that show us
that well maybe inflation is starting to
get better so here's one example before
the pandemic to import a container from
China which is where most of the goods
you see in stores today come from it
costs two thousand dollars
hide a pandemic or even a little bit
afterwards the shipping industry broke
so significantly that those containers
went up to around twenty thousand
dollars to import so if you're selling
in a retail form or anything that you
use even you know I don't know maybe
even silverware in a restaurant right so
it impacts the service industry too you
now have a 10x import cost and that's
part of the reason why rates go up the
thing is at this point
that twenty thousand dollar container
has come back down to around two three
thousand dollars so some of the supply
chain issues that have been pushing
inflation are starting to fix themselves
so you could
hope that if the rate raise campaign
stops or even rolls back a little bit
that we'll be able to see what people
are calling the soft Landing or the no
Landing scenario which is that we don't
go into recession inflation cools off we
still have like sort of got a lot of
this froth out of the economy and we
continue to grow at a normal pace so
that that could potentially be like the
situation where you know everything
turns out well but if inflation keeps up
then what is the fed's hands are kind of
tied right they you know because once
inflation gets run away your economy
doesn't work anymore it just doesn't
work and you know this right so there
has to be a range where we're able to
have an economy that works with
inflation at a reasonable pace and
that's sort of why we're in this moment
of pain as we as we are because it just
got out of hand
and so we all like sitting here you know
where we are kind of have to pray that
the FED is able to engineer the soft
Landing where it's able to roll back
interest rates we don't break too many
more things and the economy continues to
Pace but if something of of that nature
go wrong there's there really isn't a
many there really aren't many levers
that you can pull to fix it and that's
where things get kind of scary now I
happen to think that we're probably
going to end up in the softer Landing
situation maybe we have a recession but
it might it might not be devastating but
I'm open to the possibility that it's
not the positive scenario and that's
where things get really concerning
yeah the beginning of the year I made
predictions for the year and I said we
have a recession sometime this year of
some
um significance uh you know if there's a
soft landing and we have a relatively
mild dip I that to me would be really
positive at this point you know yes like
I I look at this
um it's a pick your poison situation uh
you know inflation was running very very
hot when they went on this raising
campaign as we're talking I think it's
somewhere in like the five or six
percent range
um which is well above their stated
Target of two percent uh it's better
than it was like you know I think it was
uh like eight nine ten like you know
like a little bit maybe you didn't get a
10 but it was certainly in like the high
single digits
um and so from their own stated goals
before this banking crisis uh they were
going to raise rates again uh this month
uh either or they're 0.25 or 0.5 I mean
that was really something it's like and
they might still do it and then you used
you then you started oh wow there's like
a car off the side of the road like you
know it's called Silicon Valley Bank
it's like oh there's another one
signature oh there's another one you're
gonna start like sending cars off the
side of the road
it's a big decision for them whether
they decide to go with a 0.25 or 0.5
um but in my opinion
um you have so many other uh landmines
kind of dwelling on the balance sheets
of
competitions that uh that I don't see
how you can avoid some degree of really
painful Readjustment
um and you know like you you hope that
we're gonna manage through it again I am
someone who categorically was for the
fact that we backstopped the depositors
of Silicon Valley Bank I thought that I
thought it was like obvious frankly that
that's the direction we should go in
um but it's less obvious to me what the
right answer is going to be when these
other things uh flare up and blow up
which they certainly will yeah and
Andrew I have a question for you and I'm
curious I haven't gotten too deep into
this so I might sound stupid right now
but I'm curious what you think about the
fact that when these rates go up
it potentially has the ability to send
our national debt even further if the if
we're paying out even more money on the
debt that we hold
so I'm curious what you think about that
and whether that's an issue or maybe I'm
completely off base
oh you know I mean that that was one of
like the theoretical benefits of
inflation honestly was that then your
your dollar denominated debt is worth
less I mean we're in this particular
period where the U.S dollar is still the
global Reserve currency Undisputed uh
you know like and other countries are
looking around being like man I'm tired
of using the dollar but then their big
question is what the heck else can I use
and there's really no uh no genuine
Global rival
um so our society enjoys this massive uh
luxury of having the global Reserve
currency having our debt denominated in
it the the downsides of inflation are so
direct and pressing on American
households uh and the function of the
economy that
it can go out of control and so the FED
feels like it has to tame it
um I I think you know and people can
probably tell from listening to me talk
about this I think the original error
was suppressing interest rates for so
long for so there's no doubt yeah and
they stayed basically zero for for way
way too long and created this Academy
that got accustomed again to this thing
gonna let let you know potentially
lasting forever
so I was 24 in 1999 when there was the
first bubble and I was still here in New
York so I saw I went to these glitzy
launch parties I was in the offices of a
firm called silicon alley recruiter
where all they did is they recruited for
tech companies they had this big office
downtown and then I saw all of that
evaporate in a matter of weeks where
like the the office was empty the
company that I went to the launch party
of was bankrupt and I was like oh my
gosh like that turned very dramatically
by the way I was a uh you know
co-founder of this tiny internet company
myself so I got to directly experience
the the pain and I got all of that stuff
downloaded into me at the age of 25. so
I was like okay I get it
and then
lo and behold in 2008 like uh it's you
know uh I'm uh um it's happening again
and I'm just like oh my gosh I gotta
remember this so it's wild each time
like the extremes have gotten more
extreme
um you know I I do think that the easy
money has been going for so long that
um that you've warped the incentives of
a lot of people and a lot of
Institutions a lot of organizations
you've channeled our talent
um in in particular ways something that
you see every day because when you're
covering big Tech you know a lot of
these people like had a lot of ability
and you think to yourself like oh I wish
they were building something that helped
Mankind and you know like
and didn't necessarily just like you
know go like help this Mega tech company
that may or may not be helping mankind
at this point so so there's been this
this epocal uh set of incentives
um it and the the path out of it you
know as you can tell I think is going to
be really really Rocky the big thing I
would say to folks is check out those
freaking savings accounts check out
those rates you know like you show up
like you'd be like wow I can lock up my
money for only like you know nine months
and they'll pay me like four point
something percent
um you know like that that's one of the
only upsides of this time for like the
the average person well look you know
this is not investment advice so take it
for what it's worth exactly it's not
it's also it's also a a benefit for some
of your your younger listeners right so
in 20 20 21 the S P 500 was up like 32
percent
and last year contracted this year it
might contract which is very rare for
the s p to go to contract two years in a
row so if you're like 25 and you're not
going to retire for another 30 years
like this is absolutely a great moment
to dip your toe in the market and maybe
invest in the S P 500 Index Fund or
maybe invest in a a cross Market you
know ETF and that gives you some
exposure to the downside over the next
what's going to be probably a year maybe
two but you know on average you're going
to double your money every seven years
if you just look at the Historical value
of like the growth of the S P 500 so if
you're going to retire you know in the
next couple years you know go go to
those savings rates now but if you're
going to be a long-term investor in the
market I mean there's really there's
it's it's a great moment to jump in and
you know maybe not put it all at one
point but you know keep going little by
little and then reap the rewards of this
of of you know if you don't need the
money within the next two years you know
reap the rewards over the time max out
your 401K get that in the market and
over time that's going to really be
beneficial to you
spoken like a true Millennial Alex I
like it you know I I think it's
important for people just to understand
the context of what we're in because
it's hard to understand it when you're
living it
um and for most people like a lot of
people listening to this probably
weren't alive in the 70s I was barely
alive in the 70s you know and so like
yeah you have to to to look back 50
years to see when the country was in a
similar Zone
um I do think that you know find like
financial sector is a much bigger part
of the economy cheap money was available
for much longer like you know I I don't
see how this adjustment's not going to
be a really really difficult one
um but I just think people should
understand what's happening so that they
can add a minimum to your point just
like you know learn lessons from this
time be like okay like that that you
know like that that time uh we were
going through like a you know maybe uh
like certainly a stock market
contraction
um banking failures and some other
things
that that might be singular to this time
and you know and then there might might
be different types of uh periods ahead
it's so great to get that lesson early
and that's why like when we had these
this meme stock event you know everyone
was like we have the institutional
investors leading young people down the
road that you know they'll never they'll
never recover from and they're the bag
holders and I'm like okay yes it's
probably true in some ways but it's not
all bad because getting to experience
one of these moments right maybe making
money in the stock market for the first
time or losing money in the stock market
for the first time
generally it doesn't scare people off
from the rest of their life and they
find a way to get back in and get
smarter and if you're 21 years old and
you're on Wall Street bets on Reddit and
you're following these waves and maybe
you put a little in or maybe you just
watch how it goes and then your aperture
expands all of a sudden like how do I
make money in the stock market right
like I wish 21 year old me had been
watching that and understood that when I
came out of college
putting maxing out my 401k and putting
it in the market would have been the
best thing I could have done for my
future and maybe that's what's happening
to young people today
yeah hopefully there are lessons that
are going to be learned you know you
want to be positive uh that that and I
gotta say like my 20s were a very very
deep education that yeah like how lucky
were you to have that experience it's
amazing and Alex I actually said that to
myself all the time I was like I'm
really glad I got this stuff in my 20s
yeah because I was hard bitten after
that uh you know like and uh being a
failed entrepreneur in your 20s I mean
it feels like the end of the world but
to your point uh you know like life goes
on and you've got a lot of time ahead of
you exactly
well Alex thank you for your time and
insight if people want to keep up with
you and your work covering technology
how can they do so I would just
recommend going to Big technology
podcast I have uh again this interview
with these two Silicon Valley insiders
today talking about what the bank meant
to the industry and
what Silicon Valley is going to do now
that its reputation is so clearly
unpopular so I think that might be fun
Kevin Systrom the founder of Instagram
is coming on next week and we talk about
the week's news every Friday I'm just
breaking down what happened and Andrew
Mann I hope we can get you on one time
would be great to to chat with you about
everything sure thing Alex I'll come
when there's the the next uh major
crisis uh Alex cantorowitz thanks for
for joining us I'll see you soon thank
you guess we'll have you on the show
next week then yeah yeah seriously it
might be next week
foreign